okay let's talk about
the legendary john mcafee that's about
john mack have you ever seen this
documentary about it i've seen parts of
it okay that's a weird dude man yeah
i have more questions in the documentary
eric you've seen his documentary
have you ever seen us have you seen this
documentary or no i want to
i want to watch it i mean i have not
seen it yet no well you may change your
mind after you watch it oh okay
have you watched it any one of you guys
okay so here's what just happened with
john mac we indicted for tax evasion
accused of hiding cryptocurrency uh
yacht from irs anti-virus software
pioneer mcafee was indicted
the prominent money tax division amazon
kevin became outrageous and erratic
behavior from tech entrepreneur the
indictment
alleges mcafee millions from promoting
cryptocurrencies consulting work
speaking engagements and selling the
rights to his
life story for a documentary but did not
file tax returns
from 2014 to 2018 authorities also
alleged mcafee concealed assets from the
irs including real estate iata car and
cryptocurrency was indicted on june 15
but the document was unsealed
etc etc etc so mcafee is facing even
more legal trouble on monday he was sued
by the sec for improperly
promoting cryptocurrency icos thoughts
on mcafee is he going to do time i mean
will he actually step foot
in a jail in prison this guy i remember
following him
in like ink magazine or the big business
magazines and they'd all
all these profiles on him how did he get
caught he was so good
at being evasive and they caught him in
spain and then they're going to
extradite him here
but what what a classic case of uh you
know
the strings just ran out on this guy
right ended
the chances of him going to jail very
slim all right is
he what country is he in spain is that
where he is
extradition is that even happening no i
think it is
by the way the sec filing was 55 pages
long that's how
thick the dossier was on the charges wow
for this guy
what was your take on him from you you
interviewed a sit-down interim two-hour
interview with this guy what was your
take on this
brilliant guy though right so i tell you
i'm i thoroughly
enjoyed my sit down with him but i'm
gonna give you the back story
where was the place i'll tell you
exactly what the backstory was so so i'm
in nashville tennessee doing some
business and i'm meeting with arthur
laffer which
you know from the laffer curve arthur
lafrey was on the bush
uh advisor for on the finance side with
reagan with
he's done stuff with george he's doing
stuff with a lot of different people
okay so
we're in tennessee uh we're at barnes
and noble
and mario is in communication with uh
mac if his camp
so they call and they say okay great
mcafee is ready if you guys want to have
a meeting with them
where at his house okay we don't have
the address we start driving to his
house
we pull up to his house i'm on a call
with tom
i'm in my car mario and luis go inside
to set up okay no joke i'm in my car
i'm talking to tom i'm like i'll be
inside a different town yeah yes it
wasn't you i'm i'm gonna phone this this
is three years ago this is three years
ago so
mario and luis go inside to set up and
all of a sudden mario text me
pat they're not comfortable with you
being in the car like i'll finish the
call you said no no you have to come
inside they just frisked us
i said they just went they said they
just risked us
and our buddy luis wasn't too
comfortable about the situation
so i'm not gonna i'll come inside to see
what's going on so i i go inside they're
all looking at me funny like who the
hell is this guy
like hey fellas how you doing and tat it
up
10 ak-47s on the table right there 10.
this is cuba i'm giving you a low number
i'm giving you for real this isn't
that's tennessee yes okay so we go
inside the guys were like
who are you like hey what's up how you
doing i'm patrick beth david you know so
who i said so who are you i'm a former
u.s
army ranger i'm a former navy seal on
their towers
oh that's great i served at the hunter
first airborne what was your mos
63 bravo it's a hotel eight specialized
i can go out there and do some stuff
with the
you know some of the trucks that i had a
bunch of fm tvs lmtvs at 1500 myself
what unit were you at three two six
engineers get the [ __ ]
give him a come here man bring out the
good whiskey man we're gonna have some
all of us hey listen we got a couple
girls upstairs you want to go upstairs
he says it's good before the interview i
said no i'm totally fine bro and i'm
like
my mario luis you cannot i'm teasing you
there's literally girls upstairs then
all of a sudden all you hear is
like something is opening okay and you
hear
eight german shepherds just barking all
over run around
loud this is loud we're in the
cul-de-sac
house is on the bottom back is wide open
with a bunch of land
and these dogs are i said what's going
on this oh john is here okay great
so we're going john shows up with his um
girl
and uh he comes in keeps wiping his nose
like
50 times and allergies allergies yeah at
the time it's a very
big allergy season so we sit down to do
the interview he's got a gun right here
okay on him while we're doing the
interview in the middle of the interview
it's about 43 minutes into the interview
i believe
in the middle of the interview uh
somebody knocks on the door this person
knocks on the door i'm just kind of like
i'm not even paying attention to the
interview
i'm just matter of fact if you pull it
up you got to pull it up go to john
magnus interview
in the middle of the interview i'm
sitting there and i'm talking to him
somebody knocks on the door
one of the rangers jumps up to the door
with a gun who goes there
who goes there in the middle of the
interview crap yeah i haven't told you
the story oh
okay type in john maxwell i can't
believe he agreed to do an interview
okay so go right there click on that and
uh
uh uh uh just
mute the audio until i can find the
location uh keep going keep going slowly
and okay
keep going keep going keep going keep
going keep going nervous
right there okay well oh that's going
keep going keep going keep going keep
going keep going keep going keep going
it should come up any minute now when a
guy walks if you go little so you guys
got to see
that straight vodka he's drinking yeah
it's straight vodka is drinking by the
way all of a sudden
i want to really find this because you
have to see the reaction that's what was
crazy about it
my camera guy was so worried
he thought it's over he thought there's
gonna be a shooting keep going a little
faster to see if anything comes up
he right there okay 43 minutes i don't
remember that but 43 minutes okay watch
this okay
pause it go back five seconds
let's hear what's going on make it um
watch this to um to ecuador from hong
kong the last country
i'd go through was russia you've got 50
different options
or even direct flights from hong kong to
ecuador why the heck
is he going through um russia
holy crap so um
so i you know it's hard for me
to say is it good
looks like honduras or something by the
way you didn't edit that out of the
internet
ask you to stop rolling not at all you
didn't even blink
i didn't even blink it even but the
point is this so but you know these are
some of the stories people tell me like
oh whatever it's being exaggerated
that's exactly what happened
all the time great when you have a story
like that you can say let me show you
right
you got the video i have a story like
that do you remember calvin ayer
he was the founder of bowdog.com the
online gambling site he was on the cover
of the forbes billionaire issue yeah
probably about 12 years he was just an
eccentric crazy guy i used to own this
magazine
called post and it was a great magazine
it was a luxury lifestyle magazine in
sports magazine so
we just went into athletes homes and
never showed him in uniform and
ballers man it was just a cool magazine
he loved it he was living in costa rica
and vietnam and vancouver but he loved
the magazine because we sent it to him
so he flew to phoenix twice to go to a
couple of our parties
right just to come he flew to phoenix
from costa rica and then he he taught me
how to the only time i've ever played
poker in my life one time
he taught me how to play texas hold him
and i kind of learned for 15 minutes but
that was it i was horrible at it
then he invites me to costa rica and i
go out there and we're going to do this
photo shoot with him
and we show up and and you know we're
going man it would be cool we did
something in the bathtub oh hang on he
makes a call he has five chicks over
there in a second
in the bathtub with a rubber ducky and
then hey he shows up at the door he
opens up the door he had a post magazine
t-shirt on
and with a glass of vodka at nine in the
morning and then you look around and he
had he lived on a calder or on a
residential street but he owned
two houses each on each side just for
security he had a bulletproof hummer
you know the whole thing just like that
and i'm going to myself this is a
tuesday night for this guy this is
totally
normal this is an average day for this
guy how do you keep up that pace
yeah so some of the by the way here
here's a crazy story about john mcflurry
so this interview is happening we have a
good time
we leave we're having all this
conversation together we post a video
and uh there's a couple comments he made
about the uh
price of cryptocurrency he said it's
gonna go up to forty eight thousand
dollars
in a different interview anyways long
story short
one of the short clips gets five six
million views in the span of like a
couple days when we post on facebook
okay
mcafee is got probably some of the most
loyal followers in the crypto world that
people need to know this he has a
following
in the crypto world like no other they
adore this guy they love this guy at the
same
time he has a lot of haters in the
cryptocurrency world
that can't stand it because some claim
that he tells people don't sell crypto
but he sells us crypto
and then it goes down it's so easy to do
marketing like a pump and dump type it's
so easy to do that with crypto right
on the back end so you know in his
documentary
there's a lot of weird stories one of
the stories was you know uh
he had all these dogs in the back and
his dogs were playing his next-door
neighbor
who sold this company apparently and he
retired and he bought a house right next
to him in the caribbean i think it's in
the caribbean's
he retires like listen john i didn't
come here to have a dog bark in a
backyard non-stop
i made all my money to go to an island
and retire so i can do whatever i want
to do
and you're next to me every day i have
to hear about dogs barking
he says i can do whatever i want to do
it's my property mcafee says this
apparently
allegedly long story short the owner of
this house gets pissed off
he puts a poison in a meat throws it
over
mcafee's dog eats it mcafee comes back
with his dog dead
and they find that he ate poison and
then he finds that this guy did it he
hires somebody go take him out so he
gets killed the neighbor gets killed no
yes so this is the guy so this
is the guy you're talking about anyways
so that's one of the part of stories who
he marries in a documentary says who'd
you marry says this is my wife
she says he said he says why'd you marry
her she gives the best
[ __ ] i've ever had in my life this is
what he says
in the documentary says that's why i
married her i just want you to know this
that's marriage material for him boom
this is this is why i say you may not
enjoy the documentary okay
so you're talking about a guy like this
john mcafee it's where he's at right
so what's this again what's going to
happen to him if john mc if social media
was around
when john mcafee was first coming up and
he sold mcafee
he would have probably had 50 million
followers he's one of the original
playboys all these guys i wanted to be
playboys
they followed a lot of his steps of what
he did he was one of the original
playboys
on what he did so what's going to happen
to him i think when you're playing with
fire and you need a lot of attention and
you're
no longer getting the kind of attention
you did at one point you're it's
your time's going to come it's not like
you can't do this forever
and when it comes it's not pretty it is
not going to be pretty because
rumor has it in the streets he's running
out of money yeah and when you're
running out of money you do desperate
things when you start doing desperate
things you eventually get caught
how do you think he is now i'm gonna put
him in his early 60s oh
i don't know his age i'm going to put
him in the early 60s he looks like a
loose cannon like
who knows here's the big question he's
falling off
what do you think john mcafee tells his
kids when he's having that sex talk with
them
i bet that's a give them marry the girl
yeah what i do is i look for the woman
who has no teeth that's what i do and i
marry her that's john mcafee you know
what i'm glad
i'm glad he got arrested after hearing
all these stories i hope he goes to jail
yeah karma man it caught up with him
even in the comments right now we have
people being like he's the man he's epic
yeah
i'm telling people are like he's a
scumbag he's the worst that's exactly
part
exactly polarizing exactly who he is but
guys leave a comment what you think
about this guy john mcafee
epic or the worst what you have to
realize is he
is who he is he's telling there's
nothing about him that he hides down
authentic that's the part meaning at
least the the benefit about a guy like
this is
he's telling you this is who i am yeah
he's not making stuff up to make himself
look good like that he just said this is
who i am love me or hate me it is
exactly
where were the threats coming from where
he had to have that type of firepower
backing him up did he have legit death
threats or was that just part of his
persona let me put it to you this way he
said
he said i don't use regular phones he
says i have the kind of a phone right
now that i would never use
i can't get any information i want out
of your phone the guy was
you know there's a level of paranoia you
know only the paranoid survive
but there's also the level where you
skip it you can get close to
schizophrenia like you start
imagining like the world is after you
and all this other stuff i mean if you
got that kind of worry about people
coming after you're not living a good
life it's a very difficult life to live
i mean you get a knock on the door and
all of a sudden you're
you're busting out your guns there yeah
exactly it's the craziest thing right
there
i gotta give you credit you've got guns
all around you you've got a drunk
psychopath with a gun on them interviews
pat didn't flinch knock on the door that
will not be revealed
but one day some people will reveal it
it's just some parts of
so thumbs up thumbs down for your take
on this guy
about what just overall like look you
can't
here's the reality of it who likes
paying taxes
who who who has ever said i love paying
taxes
trump 750
dollars is what
but the one thing you can't do it's this